une journée typique dans la vie d'un
caravanier qui suit un chef de partie ça
ressemble un peu à ça
[Musique]
ça commence souvent par une réunion avec
les affectateurs rédacteurs en chef et
les autres caravaniers des autres partis
on discute des annonces qui sont prévues
pour la journée mais aussi ce qui s'est
passé dans les événements de campagne la
veille et ce qui pourrait être le plus
porteur comme sujet pour la journée
évidemment lors des annonces les
journalistes posent toutes sortes de
questions sur toutes sortes de sujets et
souvent la réponse devient la nouvelle
et vient éclipser l'annonce c'est pour
ça que les mains et les pressent et les
questions des journalistes sont si
importantes on fait aussi beaucoup de
route mais la majorité du temps on le
voit pas vraiment passer ce temps-là
parce qu'on l'utilise pour faire de la
rédaction d'articles des directs aussi à
la radio à la télé et parfois seul avec
notre iPhone entre tout ça il y a aussi
beaucoup de bains full des événements de
campagne des assemblées populaires le
travail d'un caravaning c'est aussi donc
d'être là d'avoir des yeux et des
oreilles tout le tour de la tête si
jamais il y a une déclaration une
rencontre avec un citoyen qui va marquer
la campagne
alors c'est aujourd'hui moi que je
quitte la caravane libérale je vais me
diriger dans la caravane kakis
[Musique]
toujours en mi campagne à Montréal parce
que tous les autobus se rencontrent ici
pour le débat des chefs et je vous avoue
que ça va faire du bien de changer
d'autobus pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
c'est qu'en micampagne on entre dans un
espèce de brouillard on s'est plutôt que
on sait plus quelle journée on est rendu
on voit les chefs 3 4 des fois cinq fois
par jour pour leur poser des questions
et puis là à un moment donné on se dit
il me semble j'ai posé toutes les
questions qu'est-ce qui me reste à
demander le fait qu'un collègue vienne
me relayer c'est des nouvelles questions
nouvelles énergies une nouvelle
adrénaline des nouveaux sujets abordés
comme si on repart le compteur à zéro
finalement aussi l'autre raison pour
laquelle les médias changent l'autobus
c'est qu'il faut comprendre qu'en
campagne électorale des journées de 12
13 14 même 15 heures par jour c'est hors
du tout alors on pense beaucoup de temps
avec le personnel politique beaucoup de
temps avec les chefs aussi et on est
tous des êtres humains on peut très bien
s'entendre ou ne pas s'entendre du tout
et je parle d'un strictement personnel
parce que les journalistes ont demandé
neutres dans leur travail donc après
certains temps il faut changer d'air ça
permet de conserver une distance qui est
vraiment très importante dans notre
travail une indépendance finalement par
rapport au parti parce qu'on s'en va en
boire un autre on est à Montréal je
monte à bord de l'autobus du Parti
québécois on prend la route pour le
Saguenay puis la côte nord à bord on est
une quinzaine il y a le chauffeur salut
Jean des collègues des médias
Jean-Sébastien chef d'émission du Parti
québécois qui est aussi un peu comme
notre nounou d'autres membres de
l'équipe se trouve à l'arrière et
contrairement à la situation dans les
autres autobus ici le chef voyage avec
nous il se trouve au fond complètement
dans une pièce spécialement aménagée
bonjour là on vient de s'arrêter prendre
à manger après quoi je viens à la
cuisinette me faire un café au début de
la campagne j'étais avec le Parti
conservateur qui avait pas de machine à
café les journalistes ont bien failli se
rebellir
si vous vous demandez d'ailleurs le PQ
prévoit compenser les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre provoquées par ces
déplacements en collaboration avec
l'entreprise carbonate Québec ils
prévoient mettre en terre plus de 70
arbres et finalement à peine 48 heures
plus tard cette
île évidemment tous les arrêts sont
stratégiques la circonscription de
Jonquières par où on est passé et celle
de Duplessis ici sont parmi les derniers
bastions du Parti québécois l'autobus a
déjà dévoré plus de 6000 km et on repart
dans quelques heures déjà pour Montréal
en prévision du débat une grosse partie
du travail en campagne électorale pour
un chef comme Madame anglaise c'est
d'aller rencontrer des citoyens
directement sur le terrain établir un
contact avec ces gens-là comme ce qu'on
est en train de faire aujourd'hui au
grand marché de Québec serrer des mains
parler du programme politique comprendre
aussi quels sont les préoccupations des
gens
[Musique]
mais au-delà du travail de terrain ce
que vous voyez peut-être moins c'est que
toute une armée de bénévoles dans les
parties qui travaillent pour faire
sortir le vote parce que l'on voit les
sondages ça peut avoir l'air serré par
exemple pour le Parti libéral le Parti
québécois Québec solidaire le Parti
conservateur sauf que ces électeurs-là
sont des sympathisants faut trouver un
moyen de les amener aux urnes notre 3
octobre dimanche et lundi c'était jour
de votre part anticipation puis madame
anglaise elle est allée prêter main
forte justement pour faire sortir le
vote elle s'est rendu dans deux bureaux
de circonscription dans le sien et
d'aller rejoindre le bénévole elle a
fait des téléphones avec eux et le but
c'est de savoir les électeurs de sa
circonscription et ce qu'ils pensent de
son côté ou non c'est ce qu'on appelle
faire du pointage et dans l'accumulation
de données le parti finit par savoir
est-ce que ça s'enlève bien ou pas pour
cette circonscription là le jour des
élections et ça va même plus loin que ça
parce que des fois il y a des électeurs
qui disent au téléphone moi j'ai pas les
moyens de me rendre au bureau de scrutin
du jour du vote et alors le parti va
proposer un transport gratuit pour la
personne donc valait la chercher chez
elle pour l'amener au bureau de vote et
puis s'assurer que la personne puisse
finalement voter pour le parti de cette
journée là